if men don't shave it sort of just seen
as a fashion choice I feel like if women
don't shave a lot of times it's seen as
like a political choice we convinced
four of our co-workers to give up
shaving for a month to see how their
perspectives would change this is what
happened I am so excited because I hate
shaving so much I'm excited but I'm
nervous there's gonna be like all the
spirits social anxiety yeah I think part
of me is kind of excited to have an
excuse to not say I've done no-shave
November before so no strangers I'm not
shaving for a month I don't think I've
ever not shaved for a whole month before
I feel like I'm going to be both in
anguish and liberated at the same time
I'm the most nervous with my armpit I
have some hairy armpits I'm nervous that
like three weeks in two weeks and I'm
just gonna be like why did I sign up for
this I feel disgusting
for two weeks in to the non shaving
thing things are definitely getting
hairy
I finally crossed that line where it's
definitely doesn't look like I forgot to
shave it looks like I'm intentionally
not shaving got pretty pretty thick
beard here it's pretty pretty dense I
haven't really gotten too many crazy
looks or anything I've been wearing
short sleeve shirts because I don't want
anyone to see my armpit hair I'm hiding
my armpit hair under longer sleeved
shirt part of me really wants to start
wearing a lot of like long sleeves I'm
gonna try not to it's gonna be hard the
idea terrifies me I should be more
confident actually more comfortable I
shouldn't give a [ __ ] but it's an
adjustment it's been pretty great I
don't think there's live any issues that
save me a lot of time knife and shave I
am going to wear a tank top day and this
is what's going on side profiles the
best cuz you can see it there it is
there it is look at that oh my gosh look
at that I went to the farmers market a
in a tank top no one even noticed no one
said anything I don't think people care
that I haven't shaved people okay hey so
that was actually kind of cool this is
the last day of not shaving but a month
and I have not shaved yet this is the
end this is it we've come to the end of
the road as you can see it's getting
kind of ridiculous I finally get to take
a razor to the hair under my arms and
I'm so excited you don't have to like
dot all your i's and cross all your T's
every day in terms of your beauty
regimen to like be seen as attractive
and feel sexy I honestly feel pretty
great you could go around being as hairy
as you wanted and people don't seem to
react at all only noticed I'm convinced
I'm a narcissist because no one ever
said anything was a little liberating
I've learned that I can pull off beard
without any issue and people tend to see
this as something that this is sort of
part of my looks it's definitely a
bigger thing for girls it seems very
pointed and it has like a message to be
either feminist or to like actively say
stick it to the man or something and if
a guy is a beard no one says that you
know ultimately I think that that sort
of does highlight the the gender
inequality there sorry
yes from here on out I get to make the
actual decision about whether or not I
want to shave and right now I don't
really feel like I have to it's totally
up to you you know it's an individual
choice body hair just isn't as big of a
deal as I always thought it was I don't
think that every time you shave or put
makeup on you're just like answering to
the man or like the patriarchy but I do
think that it is empowering to try it
and realize that even if you do do
something that's kind of against the
grain of beauty you'll still feel
beautiful